hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is Steven Williams and I am a senior
scientist at 10x genomics I'll be
presenting on connecting genetic and
trip's transcriptional variation and
acute myeloid leukemia at single-cell
resolution please feel free to submit
questions during my presentation and
I'll follow up with you via email so I'd
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to give this talk first a
little some details I am an employee of
and hold shares in 10x genomics so for
our agenda mm-hmm I'll be giving a study
overview a brief and in complete history
of single cell technology and how the
10x genomics single cell works workflow
works as well as describing single
nucleotide variation detection and gene
expression in acute myeloid leukemia
so understanding cell type heterogeneity
is a huge undertaking that is just
beginning and projects like the human
cell Atlas are trying to get at this
sort of question where they're
sequencing millions of cells from all
different sorts of tissues in the human
body in fact trying to identify every
single type of cell in the human body so
acute myeloid leukemia though is the
most common form of acute leukemia and
adults affecting around 20,000 new cases
each year there is a five-year survival
rate of approximately 27% so this is a
very deadly disease it is clearly
heterogeneous which makes this cancer
very hard to study and detection of
genetically distinct and clinically
relevant subclones are essential to
understanding AML and if detected they
are hard to purify so this is where
single cell technologies can be really
important so AML is challenging cancer
for single cell gene expression based
studies because
most cells have no large-scale copy
number variation and there's also this
thing called lineage infidelity where
tumor cells can display a wide range of
phenotypes and expression signatures
matching other lineages or even
different differentiation states and
they can even look like normal cells now
AML also typically is occurs during the
blast stage which we you'll see over on
the right hand side I've put in a little
cartoon of how a blood stem cell
differentiates into different cell types
so AML is a moving target
so usually you start with steady-state
hematopoiesis you get your initiating
mutation this one isn't dnmt3a you get a
clonal hematopoiesis of intermediate
potential where say you acquire another
mutation seen in green and npm one then
you have your mo founding clone where
you have acquired enough mutations to
induce a cancerous potential then
subclones arise out of this initial
founding clone and this makes AML very
difficult because these cell clones will
have different phenotypes so then the
patient is identified they go through
chemotherapy everything hopefully is
great coming out of chemo but then so
the individual goes through remission so
if you don't get all the cancer though
then you have relapse where you have
this giant expansion of the potentially
most the most harmful clones that goes
through into relapse and this is when
this cancer becomes very deadly so what
are the sources of intramural expression
heterogeneity so most tumors are
genetically heterogeneous as most of us
probably know and they have funding
founding subplots so in single-cell RNA
see we can show this expression
heterogeneity but how
our mutations and this expression
heterogeneity related and can we
directly link mutations to expression
clusters in single-cell RNA seek data
and this will give us some powerful
insight into the biology of any given
cancer so first I'd like to give a brief
history of single cell technology so
single cell technology did not start off
with 10x genomics or drop seek or any of
the single cell technologies you may
love know and love today single cell
technology started back in 1590 by and
with the first microscope that was
invented by Zacharias Johnson who
invented the first microscope with his
father and he was some people say that
he was approximately thirty eleven to
thirteen years old but this happened so
he could use this device to go look at
water samples and see all these cool
bugs that were floating around that no
one would be able to was able to
identify before that so next Galileo
invented what he called Akio lino and
Akio Nino means little eye and this was
basically a similar device that he put
on a stand and you can use a candle to
eliminate the sample then Alan Anthony
then ludovic invented this device that
you'll see on the right hand side which
gave 200 times magnification in 1670 and
this was a huge leap forward because
then you can really start getting at
single cells of state plants or other
sort of organisms and in 1840 jumping
forward a good long ways Carl Zeiss and
Ernst Abbe invited the invented the
first microscope with a stand and it had
a mirror that would reflect light up
into your sample and so this really
looks like what you might expect to see
in the modern-day microscope and this
provided huge leaps board and being able
to look at blood and and other samples
that really just weren't tractable until
now in 1840
to Carl and Niguel II saw the very first
chromosomes which he observed in plants
in 1912 Hans von Witte water actually
saw the first human chromosomes and he
said yeah humans have 47 chromosomes and
he was wrong and then he said wait no
humans have 48 chromosomes and then
finally he came to the conclusion that
yes humans have 46 chromosomes which
gave rise to Kim sustaining and G
banning where we could really start to
get at the bulk and our gross morphology
of single chromosomes and actually see
some of their innate structure so in
1982 fish was invented and could be used
to interrogate very large duplications
and deletions and translocations at
chromosome scale and then in 1996 sky
was invented kind of in parallel by two
different groups and this enabled whole
chromosome painting to easily observe a
rearrangements between chromosomes so
we're really good at investigating
single cells at chromosome scale at this
point so we're in 1996 right now so what
about getting beyond chromosome scale so
in 2009 a paper by Tang at all
identified or sequence the very first
whole transcriptome analysis of a single
cell and at this point bulk DNA and RNA
sequencing is breaking through leading
to lots of discoveries and enabling us
to untangle the complexity as a jak
disease but in this study they actually
isolated seven single cells that were
hand-picked and sequence very deeply so
this was truly a single-cell experiment
in 2012 fluid I'm came out with their c1
which could potentially sequence up to
96 cells in theory but in reality the
sure rate is much lower now they have a
device out that can sequence up to 384
cells so in 2015 the drop seek was
invented by McAfee ofl from Steve
McArdle's lab and this was the first
fluidics based approach that allowed for
high-throughput capture of many
bar-coded
single cells using a bead based approach
where you flow your auto coated beads in
on the right you'll see on the left-hand
side with your cells and capture them in
oil
however the capture rate of drop seek is
extremely low making this road approach
risky for precious samples also this is
a DIY system with high lab to lab
variability in 2017 Grace Zen who
happens to be my boss published the
description of the very first all-in-one
single cell capture platform with a very
high capture rate and very low doublet
rate this was named the 10x chromium
system which can process from a hundred
to ten thousand cells with very high
capturing making it ideal for precious
samples as well as high throughput
experiments so this was not an
exhaustive list of techniques there are
other techniques like plate based split
pool techniques laser micro deception
dissection and of course fax based
sorting so the number of single cells
that one can process has really grown an
exponential rate over time we first
started with you know seven cells and
then to tens of cells so this is just a
non exhaustive list of what's been
sequence today and you can see up in the
upper right-hand corner a couple years
ago 10x genomics released the million
neuron dataset which you can download on
website which was a huge endeavor by our
lab and is a great resource for those
especially studying in the field of
neuroscience so how does the 10x
genomics chromium system work this is a
micro fluidics system that works at Pico
scale so at 10 x we developed a platform
to address this the immense biological
complexity I'm going to want to redo
this slide so I'll describe the 10 X
platform so we developed a platform that
addresses immense biological complexity
by enabling millions of injured
individual reactions to be performed in
a single experiment we achieve this
using a micro fluidics droplet based
approach that I'll discuss in more
detail but this droplet formation is
shown here so on the left hand side we
have gel beads that are coated with an
awl ago that has an individual barcode
which is then flowed through our micro
micro fluidics chip where your sample is
then encapsulated in oil with this gel
bead forming what we call a gem so your
sample can either be a single cell or it
can be DNA which is utilized in our link
read product but today I'll be talking
about at this single-cell sequencing so
let's talk a little bit more in detail
about C single cell seeding synthesis
with gel beads in emulsion which is the
foundational part of 10x genomics so on
the left hand side you can see we have
our gel bead which is attached to your
true seat read one so this is all set up
for Illumina sequencing we have a 16
base pair of cell barcode this is one of
700 thousand different barcodes that we
have we have a um I or unique molecular
index and our templates which all ago so
polyadenylated
mRNA is bound with the poly DT primer
and reverse transcription begins
creating a full-length CD and a copy of
them are
with C overheads which is important for
using this templates which I'll go next
the product is bound to the gel bead and
template switching occurs you are left
with a full-length CD and a tag with all
the necessary sequence to go into a
standard aluminum preparation so while
this method yields full-length cDNA
you're going to go through and do
cheering so that you're actually left
with shorter in insert sizes and this
method will yield the majority of
sequencing information on the 5 prime
end of the transcript so in this study
we use our five prime capture kit we
also have a three pronged capture kit as
well so let's get down to the meat of
this study so single-cell mRNA
sequencing and snv detection in acute
myeloid leukemia
so variant discovery in single-cell RNA
sequencing is really hard so coverage
spikes can be huge and this gives
variant callers a really hard time so
collars like gatk have built in down
samplers that don't play nice with huge
coverage spikes so here's a DVD you of a
single cell experiment that we used in
this case and you can see we have a
3,000 X coverage and if your allele
frequency is or your mutational cell
mutation frequency is very low you could
just down simple yourself right out of
being able to see any cells single cell
sequencing is sparse not every variant
will be expressed and not every variant
will be able to be captured so given the
amount of sequencing performed not every
molecule of RNA will be detected at
every position because we're not doing
full-length sequencing only one read per
transcript is identified and this is
enabled using argue amaya technology
using IBM eyes so this is really
important in a great tool in getting
good gene expression profiling and
eliminating the case where you have
lots of pcr duplication so you will have
a five prime three prime bias depending
on which kit you use on the top here you
can see the the barcode with hooked up
with the um I and templates which I'll
ago and on the bottom you can see that
you have your read one with your barcode
um I and your poly D ta sequence so in
this study we used a tool that we
developed at 10x genomics Club far
tricks VAR tricks is a single cell
genotyping tool it is and I'll explain
the things that are tricks is and the
things that bar tricks is not and on the
right hand side you can see the workflow
on how are tricks works Bar tricks is
open source it's available on our github
page it is completely free to download
and use it is implemented in rust so
that makes it really really fast and
memory efficient it provides multiple
output modes to enable downstream
analyses now the things that var var X
is not var X is not officially supported
by 10x genomics while it's a great tool
and you can feel free to use it and you
can submit issues on the github page our
support team will not will not support
this bar tricks is not a variant calling
tool it is a genotype ur so you need to
know your variants ahead of time so our
approach in this AML study was kind of a
complicated one so we used cryopreserved
ml bone marrow cells from patients and
we split these bone marrow cells into
two tracks so the first was on the top
you can see we use the 10x genomics
chromium system to do single-cell RNA
sequencing we captured approximately
20,000 cells per case with approximately
3 billion reads per run we align these
reads using the ended barcode processing
and transcript counting and then I'll
quickly run down to the bottom part of
this we also did whole genome
enhanced whole genome sequencing and
bulk RNA sequencing so we got
approximately 45 X coverage we have our
whole genome sequencing we did our
alignment and variant calling and
confirmed these variants within the bulk
RNA sequencing and then we did our
integration and we did our mutant cell
identification using our tricks and from
there as you can see on the bottom right
hand corner the we're able to overlay
mutational profiles onto gene expression
profiling as seen here in this TC plot
and we'll be looking at a lot more of
these as my talk goes on so the first
thing you might ask yourself is alright
so we've got this single-cell RNA
sequencing we've got this bulk RNA
sequencing and we've got this whole
genome sequencing so how do they
correlate with each other so on the left
hand side you can see our bulk RNA
sequencing and our whole genome
sequencing variant allele frequencies
correlate really really well the end of
the gene is expressed RNA sequencing is
going to pick it up and you'll see that
on the bottom the whole genome
sequencing obviously is going to pick up
everything so knowing that how does our
single-cell RNA sequencing correlate
with our whole genome sequencing so in
the bottom axis you can see your whole
genome sequencing very little frequency
and on the y-axis you can see the mutant
cell fraction which is essentially a
variant allele frequency so this is just
counting how meant egde of cells
detected have the mutation of interest
and the correlations are really nice so
there we detected many many variants
both at the 5-prime and 3-prime ends of
of the each transcript which might be
really surprising given that we are
capturing at the 5 prime end so we went
in and said ok this is kind of strange
it's great but women expect that you
would have almost all your reads aligned
to the 5 prime end of the transcript
given that you are capturing there so
I'm going to actually look at the
bottom trace the orange trace first so
this is our fried crime kit from all the
AML or actually this is one
representative sample from the AML case
and on the y-axis this is the fraction
of you my cell barcode pairs that were
observed so this is your Umi which is
your unique molecular index and your
cell barcode which represents one cell
so you can see that there is a big peak
or on the I should explain the x-axis so
in the x-axis this is the distance away
from the 5 prime end so you can see that
the majority of the variants that were
detected in these cells were on way
towards the 5 prime end but we're
getting a substantial amount of reads
very distant from the 5 prime end and up
to 10 KB which is as far as we looked
and this set it's similar for the 3
prime catch so we capture on the 3 prime
end you're getting most of the variation
detected on the 3 prime end but you are
getting detection of mutations very
distant from this and the reason for
this happening is still kind of a
mystery but we do have some
possibilities for this for this
phenomenon so the most likely case is
that you've got uh Nana tainted
transcript which end much closer to the
5 prime end of the gene in the 5 prime
case and so you would start your your
reads very distant to what you might
expect to be your 5 prime end there
could be internal poly ace which would
enable you to prime much closer to the 5
prime end you could have miss priming
with your templates which I'll ago or
you could have early template switching
and very similar to with the 3 prime kit
and I think that but also having uh Nana
Tate 'add transcript transcription start
sites may be closer that may be closer
to the 3 prime end is the likely case so
the single-cell RNA seek recapitulates
bulk transcript cover
so this was also an important control
for us to look at so here are a few
genes that we investigated in one case
t-50 p53 MP one got a two and dnmt3a
and you can see that we are getting
coverage all across these genes and you
can see that for bulk RNA sequencing
which is shown in purple this is the
read depth and then in for single-cell
RNA barcode depth so this is the number
of cells that have at least one read at
any given position of we're getting very
highly correlated depth at each of these
and in the green arrows you can see this
is where in this case a mutation was
detected by whole genome sequencing and
so you can see for each of these cases
we have reads it those positions and
we're able to detect detect mutations
there so now I'll give a little overview
of the five cases that we investigated
so we did whole genome sequencing RNA
sequencing and single-cell RNA
sequencing on all of these we for these
cases we detected between 31 and for
excuse me 41 and 14 whole genome
variants of which a variety of these
were expressed so your ability to detect
these samples or these mutations in
whole and single cell sequencing is
limited by expression because if it's
not expressed you're not going to detect
it and they were there on the bottom you
can see the key variants for each of
these individuals so we brought two
libraries for each of these cases doing
10,000 cells per prat we sequence them
very deeply and you can see our mean
read death per sample is approximately
200,000 we sequence all of these samples
to saturation
meaning we captured pretty much
everything that we could however this
does not mean that every molecule of RNA
is sequence fully as there is only one
read per molecule of RNA
and that's able to be identified by
using our um ah
so in these individuals you can see the
mutations are in well-established driver
genes and we actually did do a
calculation of what are false positive
rate of mutation detection and single
cells was and it's approximately 0.4
percent and here I have highlighted
where these mutation how many cells were
identified having these mutations in
each case so I'm going to be showing a
lot of TCE plots from here on out and
for those of you that aren't familiar
with TCE i'm going to go through and
give a little overview so this was
originally described by van der Mann and
in this manuscript entitled visualizing
high dimensional data using T State here
are the things that T Steen does it
visualizes visualizes a high dimensional
data in space gives you some indication
of how you're clustering wet of your
different cell types things that are
closer together should be related things
that each need does not do at least in
this study it does not cluster the cells
we use a graph based clustering approach
it does not reduce the dimensions you
need to put in already reduce
dimensionality into T State it does not
perform any sort of PCA but and it does
not give a very measurable indication of
how similar or different cells are to
each other especially at large distances
in T Snee space now that's not to say
that things that are clustered together
and located together aren't potentially
the same cell type it's just that the
farther you get from any given point the
less efficient you are at identifying
their relatedness so now I'm going to go
through each of these five cases so case
number one this is an indication where
mutations identified
or cells in complex samples so on the
first panel you can see we identified
all of our clusters and then encircled
our what we identified as being AML
cases and we associated these ml cases
with their expression and the clustering
was done based on the expression
profiles of each cell so we identified
two clusters that have stem progenitor
expression signatures and the
hemopoietic saccs pression signatures
were identified through the D map
database and you can see the ID of this
publication if you'd like to go look at
so two clusters have erythrocyte or
monocyte markers and AML styles can have
a variety of abnormal expression
signatures which makes this really
really hard to study and which
corresponds to different lineage in
states of differentiation so the key
thing here is without the mutational
signature analysis these would have been
mistaken for normal cells so in the far
right hand panel you can see in blue
where we captured mutations in each of
these cells so each dot represents a
single cell that was either identified
as wild-type in yellow or mutant in blue
so of overlaying progressive mutations
shows subclonal structure this
individual had a high proportion of non
AML cells so around 70 percent or so you
can see that we clustered all these
cells by their gene expression profiling
we are able to identify their lineages
we're able to identify t-50 p53
mutations SEM PA mutations and rats and
then on the right hand side you can see
that there is a control snip that we
used for bag one which was present in
almost all the cells so in this
individual which was surprising we
actually identified a copy number
variation which you can go in and read
about in our
archived publication but the cnv
analysis pairs extremely well sorry
pairs extremely well with what we
identified as AML cells through
mutational analysis so then we went
through and to do gene set enrichment
analysis so these samples are complex
header in heterogeneous expression
patterns which are seen in all the ML
cells
there's variable expression of cell
cycle genes and differentiation and my
migration genes so on the panel B right
here you can see the animal clusters
which are framed by the black box and
you can see that many of them are
identified as granulocyte neutrophil or
migration genes that are identified in
these cell clusters and myeloid
differentiation on the right hand side
you can see a more zoomed in view of of
this and with a little bit more
identification of cd4 positive cells B
cells C positive cells and then you can
see our cell cycle cell cycle
representation on the bottom half of
this heat map so in case number two this
was a case of lineage infidelity lineage
infidelity can be a really big problem
in AML and this is seen in this case as
you can see that there is founding SR f2
mutation which is present in many of the
cells but also there is a large
proportion of wild-type cells that are
clustering together so mutant cells
cluster with wild-type B cells and T
cells in this case an expression
heterogeneity did not correlate with
genetic heterogeneity and this makes
this individual very hard to study and
we're following up in subsequent
experiments so in case number three we
were able to identify sub-clonal
mutations associated with specific
expression signatures so this was
actually a really cool really cool case
so this individual had a
rnf ten mutations only in in cells that
were hemopoietic stem cell like tumor
cells and you can see that in the bottom
right hand panel the flip three mutation
is an intronic tandem repeat that can be
detected by our tool clock bar trick so
VAR tricks can identify these more
complex mutations and we see that in
this individual case number four there's
sub-clonal mutations with non-uniform
distribution so this was a very complex
case
so in this individual you have a gana 2
mutation which are restricted to one
side of the TC pot but you can see on
the left hand side that these group of
cells really dude clustered together in
a one massive blob but this signature
suggests an expression signature
associated with mutation you can see
this gradient on the bottom right hand
side forget a to this individual also
had a dnmt 3 mutation dnmt3a
and end P and one mutation so the
question is is does the expression
confound this analysis so we clustered
the cells in T sneeze which are colored
by Express normalized mutation fraction
in each cluster and so we did this to
make sure that expression wasn't
influencing our ability to accurately
describe the biology of what's going on
in this cell cell type so we wanted to
dig into this a little further so into
this got a 2 gradient which is president
case for so got it - is a key regulator
of hematopoiesis and is we're currently
mutated in AML we developed a multiple
multiple regression model to find
expression signatures associated with
this cattitude mutation now I'm just I'm
not going to go too deep into the math
here but you can basically see in our
model we included mean expression of any
gene the mutant cell fraction across the
12 animal clusters that were identified
in this individual mean cluster wise got
it to expression and selected genes
whose p-value was less than point zero
five and this enabled us to investigate
other stuff other gene expression
profiles that were associated with this
data to mutation so using regression
analysis we identified upregulated genes
that were associated with the gatah two
mutation notably this gene whose
expression is most strongly correlated
with this mutation is vim or vimentin
and is known as a key target of the gana
to spy one transcriptional circuit the
success of this method depends on a
number of factors including steepness of
the gradient and the number of mutant
cells so you can see that you want a
impaneled B you can see there's a very
steep gradient between vimentin
expression and non expression and you
can see on the panel on the right hand
side that as your mutate mutant cell
fraction goes up so does your expression
of fermented and on the bottom you can
see kind of the fleshed out biology of
how this actually works so gata2 is a
negative regulator of spy-1 which is
also named pu dot one here down here and
then if gata2 is mutate mutated and
cannot negatively regulates by one and
leads to up regulation of fermented so
we needed to do some orthogonal
validation of this biology and so we
used enrichment of CD 99 cells in these
galatea mutants
so we Flo sorted cells with high and low
CD ninety-nine expression compared
fraction of the mutant cells detected in
each group using amp con sequencing and
TC of only mutant cells shows localized
gata2 mutation while these dnmt3a cells
are randomly distributed and on the
right hand side you can see this in this
bar plot that when you have
dnmt3a mutation you do not have any
different expression of or capture of CD
99 hi Arlo cells and these are through
the legend you can see they're different
on the right hand side you can see how
we've color-coded these but when you
haven't got into mutations you can see
that CD 99 cells are highly enriched
both in the bone marrow and peripheral
blood so that's all I have for this talk
which I hope you enjoyed the conclusions
are that 10x genomics single cell gene
expression contains lots of useful
information on variants well away from
the capture site this information can be
easily extracted and overlaid with
expression based clustering using Bar
tricks and Surat and associating
mutational signatures with single cell
gene expression analysis enables new
insights into the evolution of tumors in
AML and this may help our prognosis
estimation and better treatment and
targeting like I said I mentioned during
my talk this whole study in detail is
available on bio archive and you can see
the title below and so finally I'd
really like to thank all the
collaborators that work on this project
it was a really exciting project to be
part of at Wash U Allegra petty Chris
Miller and Tim ley and at 10x genomics
Deana Church
Ian fitness and Patricks marks and so I
really appreciate your attention and
attending my talk thank you